we have a very special guest christian
thank you yes we have former uh u.s
champion sam shanklin and uh
nice to see you my friend how are you
good how are you guys doing great what
do you think of the candidates
uh it's definitely been an interesting
tournament so far in a lot of ways it's
not wildly surprising i mean one thing i
said after the match um
with uh nepalese carlson is i believe
nepo a like nepo on forum is probably by
some margin the second best player in
the world it's just often he really
struggles at the end of tournaments he
deals with losses badly he can tilt and
nepo b is just not that strong he's
really showing nepo a so far and i think
he's clearly played the best chess but
the real question can be can he buck the
trend uh that he's shown in the past
going into later rounds if he can i
think he's going to run away with his
tournaments but if not i think the
tournament's wide open there's a lot
there's been a lot of other interesting
stuff i think the guy who's probably
brought the best preparation has been
ding
and he's gotten a lot of good positions
but he's messed them up so he's clearly
off form a bit um
one thing i said before the tournament
was
i believe that there were no two players
whose combined chances of winning the
tournament exceeded 50 that is if
someone wants to make a bet with me i
would let you choose any two players you
want if i get the other six i think i'm
a favorite i'm not necessarily sure i
would still believe so today especially
if napomnishi wins i think he's a pretty
serious favorite at that point but i
still think the tournament's very open
wow definitely something that we thought
coming in today thank you for joining us
we're not letting you go sam we just
thought that was a great uh
explanation uh nepo a and nepo b that
was perfectly expressed i like that a
lot and i agree with sam completely that
he has shown incredible
willpower in this tournament i really
like the way that he played against
alireza it seemed that he was the one
surprised
and he still came back played his chess
and just destroyed his opponent
yeah for sure it was that was a
fantastic game i thought farouzia made a
very poor opening choice in in terms of
practicality um
i think this line is objectively fine
for black i just think the positions are
much harder to handle from the black
side in fact i actually had
this line exactly with duda in uh in
prague last year and you won that a very
beautiful game by the way yeah i just
completely killed him like very easily
and then the rest of the tournament he
made like five out of six and then he
went off and won the world cup so you
know it just
you know it felt like uh you know the
opening did not do him any favors there
um but yeah i mean it's it's just can
nepo keep himself together i mean i've
only played netbo twice in classical
chess but i've played nepo a once in
nepa b once and nepo a played an
absolutely brilliant game against me
like all the way through to the end
wildly complex and i like to think i
calculate pretty well but he just did it
better and he like just played this
beautiful game and eventually
in some like rook and bishop versus rook
and pawns end game and then um
and then when i played nepo b um
he played
d6 g6 e6 a6 b6 and lost in 10 moves so
are you sure that wasn't deposited
yeah i don't know it's just it really
feels like the guy is capable of
absolutely fantastic chess but he's also
capable of really mediocre chess and so
far he's shown the former and we'll just
see if that continues to the tournament
well help us out a little bit sam we do
have some of the games going on right
now and we think he's a great position
first of all sam i do want to ask you a
bit about the two american players uh
hikaru came into the event as a dark
horse and actually a wild card in uh to
the grand prix and then qualifying to
the candidates how do you see his
chances as well as fabiano's chances
um so again i don't think the chances of
any one particular player are wildly
high like before the tournament started
i would have said ding had the best
chances of anyone at i don't know 25 or
20 so even like the guy who i would say
was most likely to win before the
tournament started like i still think
much more likely than not will not win
the tournament just because it's
reasonably compact
i think the two of them have both shown
uh quite reasonable chests so far i'm a
little concerned for hikaru's position
at this point
and
it's um
why did you see ding as the favorite
because he hasn't played outside of
china in a year and a half he only
recently crossed back the 2800 barrier
and come came into the event as a rating
favorite why did you see him as the
favorite um part of it is maybe i'm just
a little bit uh
too methodical and mathematical ratings
do not lie i mean they're a strict
function of wins and losses that you've
accomplished against players i mean i in
general i do believe in the rating
system um in terms of intangibles uh
i've played all of these guys a bunch
for what it's worth and just ding has
absolutely clobbered me and everybody
else i have a totally fine score against
so just in my own personal experience
he's the one who scares me more and he's
the highest rated so like i considered
him a favorite as a result but still
like you know if you said will ding win
the candidates certainly more likely
than not the answer is no but i just
thought he had a better chance than like
any other one individual player
good sam if i can get your
input on some of the games let's start
with jan
as you say we've got
nepo a
and
as you were coming on air we saw a trade
of bishops f5 we really like what nepo's
been doing queen takes b2
take us through your thought process on
this position how you would evaluate it
if nepo wins my god is he securing a
huge lead
um i don't think there's much if i'd say
the odds of nepa winning this game are
well over 90 it just looks totally
crushing to me
give us what you think would be the most
i mean e6 certainly feels the most
thematic um i think duda is basically
begging for g6 and just hoping to like
sacrifice a piece and somehow try to
fight on with some pawns in a reasonably
solid position um
here my suspicion is white is much
better too but i think like you know
i mean basically if you told me if i put
g6 on the board will you beat magnus
with white here my answer is possibly
not but e6 just looks totally over to me
um and i think he will play it and here
it just
i don't know it just feels like
everything should crash through g6 is
fine maybe you can flick in rook b1 uh
to try to invade the seventh rank
there's just it just feels like it's
totally falling apart for black yeah i
don't know especially after this cool
move rook b i like this
one too i mean the moment you said it
and indicated uh the rook crashing
through
uh okay so that's nepo
a uh the
a lot of twists and turns going on in
this uh huge match up ali
raza as the number two seed struggling
but
maybe
an opportunity against fabi this is an
incredibly important game uh there's a
strange-looking catalan how would you
evaluate the current position so this
one i actually would struggle to give
you like a gut instinct just because i
actually it's funny because it looks
like it's symmetrical but actually this
is much more dynamic than
it appears at first glance
um i think thematically black should be
better here just because he is closer to
getting to the c file his knight on b4
is much better than white's knight on f3
the queen on h5 could definitely end up
misplaced but it's also very concrete in
that you can clearly see like moves like
knight g5 or bishop g5 or even like in
some cases i mean not now but at some
point rook d7 bishop h3 there's all
sorts of things that could happen to
black here so
i think if black can keep this position
under control he should be better uh but
that's a big if and i'm not sure if
white has like something direct here um
i don't know this one it's certainly
harder for me to know
directly who's who's better um i would
probably want to think for a bit more it
seems pretty dynamic actually what would
be your first instinct you said that
white needs to try some dynamic ideas
and i completely agree that black seems
like it's he's taking over what would be
your first instinct and what to look at
here for white
um
i don't know uh
well it would depend i mean if i want to
make a draw probably if i decide i'm
worse than i want to make a draw
probably i would look at bishop h3 i
think it's a bad bishop and we can trade
it off for a good one
if i want to be more ambitious um bishop
g5 would probably be the first thing i'd
think of um g4 is probably a little bit
too outlandish but it's not totally
ridiculous
um g4 i like it no but there's g6 and
then queen h5 yeah yeah and if queen h6
you have bishop g7 so or even just
bishop g4 and you're not going to get
mated after night g5 so yeah i would
think with white i mean it really feels
like bishop g5 should probably be the
move but
i don't really love the position
honestly um
i don't think but the other the nice
thing for white though is
i don't think it can be that terrible i
think or worse it's going to be a
slightly worse and you know ferrous is a
good player that being said furuja is
now down to 18 minutes for a full 24
moose of chess
remember no increment
yeah sure
um you mentioned uh you felt like a
karu's position
uh you you thought that dink coming into
the tournament ding was the favorite
hikaru's position at the moment hikaru
is a pawn up we just saw the move queen
c5 and there have been
different long thinks this looks
to us like one of hikaru's long things
try to break down this position for us
um if he could sam well again
thematically it feels like black should
be better i mean if he's able to play
queen takes b5 and c5 and c4 like his
moves are very straightforward and he
basically just crashes through and wins
the game so
um
i think in this line the big point is
you're trying to go give mate with white
but somehow the way black has
coordinated his pieces like if you go
rook g3 and just start swinging for the
fences i don't think you're gonna mate
after king f8
um
i don't know if king f it's the best
move but like it feels like there's not
enough pieces on the board and you're
always looking for like sacrifices
bishop h6 queen d2 but i think like
there's enough pieces that have been
exchanged that white not only does white
lack the firepower needed to actually
crash through and give mate but also
because black's pieces have been
exchanged his king has a pretty clear
route to e7 and d7 and c8 to escape if
white ever starts sacrificing too much
stuff that's awesome um
which is not necessarily always the case
if you know black has like a bishop on
e7 or something it often can actually
make the defense harder so
um
yeah i don't know i mean i don't think a
car is in objective trouble yet but the
position does look uncomfortable to me
and i don't like that he had a huge time
advantage and that's clearly gone now
and he's actually less time
burning this much time this fast means
you're somewhat uncomfortable with your
position i think
before we ask you what's on your agenda
and uh
so on i want to get your quick take on
the time control
nobody plays this time control not much
experience we're all used to the
increments
and now you only get the increment after
move 60 your perspective on the time
control used is a little embarrassing
but the first thing i'll ask is what is
the time control 40 moves in two hours
and then you get another hour until you
can reach move 60 on move 60 you get 15
minutes no you delay no
well you do get increment once you reach
move six until you meet
and then your 30 seconds start ticking
um i don't know i i don't care that much
honestly i think it's it's probably the
difference is pretty marginal i mean
there's guys out there who just love to
burn all their time down to nothing and
will burn all their time regardless of
whether they start with two hours or
whether they start with 90 minutes so
for them
i think they might struggle a bit for me
i don't see a a really substantial
difference um
i think
this time control or a more normal time
control i still think it's very likely
that whoever plays the best chess is
just going to win the tournament and i
don't think the time control will have a
huge amount to do with it okay and
what's happening in sam shanklin world
well i just got home from prague um
and now i'm actually uh stuck at home i
tested positive for covet a couple days
ago but um
finally i'm actually like feeling
totally fine i've been doing push-ups
and pull-ups and chin-ups and you know
doing my normal training and teaching
classes i'd say i feel like 90-95 fine
but you know still i should i slid until
i'm negative but uh so how do you know
you have covet well i touched the
positive oh
as well
you know there you go
nobody's getting tested anymore you
didn't have to get tested to travel did
you
no but i just like so i felt really
lousy on tuesday and i took a test and
it was positive but like within a day i
was basically feeling like 95 healthy so
you know i'm still gonna test and stay
at home until i'm negative but like it's
it's uh
i feel totally fine um
and uh
but yeah after that i have i guess next
up for me would be i have this magnus
tour uh the online events and then i
have the olympiads and then
after that i have no idea i mean there's
events i'm hopeful for but i just don't
know about uh and uh we'll see it's sort
of a tough spot in that you know you're
not really
i haven't been invited to stuff yet and
there's
when you're at like the level i'm at you
know which is you know say number 20 to
30 in the world
there's all these tournaments that
you're clearly good enough to play in
and that there's a chance that you could
get invited to but you're definitely not
guaranteed to be invited to right uh and
that you know if you were number 50 in
the world you're like yeah i'm not
getting invited and if you're number 10
in the world you're like yeah i'm
playing and here you know there's a very
real chance that you'll play and you
know that you could be competitive and
you know it could come but you're also
not guaranteed it makes it a little
harder to plan your schedule but uh i'm
basically open and um
and i'm hopeful that you know i could
for example play like uh if there's any
grand chester events that you know i got
a wild card too last year i was
obviously delighted to play and i would
love to do that again of course i
understand there's a lot of players who
also would love to play but yeah we'll
just see um but next up is olympiad
where i'll be playing for usa well first
of all play great at the olympia second
of all we'll be seeing you at the u.s
championship in october yes that is
definitely true it starts right after my
birthday
last season no i'm glad to see you in
india of course always good to see sam
shackleton represent america it will be
a great team that we're sending over
there to the olympia and thank you very
much sam for taking time out of your
covet
to join us it was our pleasure yeah it
was so great to see you guys and enjoy
the rest of the broadcast thank you very
much sam recover quickly yes
a nice idea by uh